it is a big day for clark county as
businesses have
officially expanded to 80 capacity
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at six o'clock i'm sasha loftis
we are tracking how the valley is taking
advantage of that
increase in crowds madison kimbrough
joins us live near flamingo in the 2 15
tonight
with more details madison
yes sasha there's a lot going on here at
parkway tavern flamingo check it out as
there
are a lot of people out and about
enjoying drinks and there's really a
great turnout for the kentucky derby
that is underway along with the golden
knights game that's happening later
tonight
the clark county commission approved the
plan on april 20
to increase capacity limits for public
gatherings along with reduced social
distancing measures
now additionally businesses currently
closed including night clubs and adult
entertainment
may reopen today as well under statewide
guidance governor sisilak hopes to have
everything reopened back to 100 percent
by june 1st
here's reaction we got from a visitor on
the strip along with here at parkway
tavern on flamingo
davis is ready and it's good it's
beautiful
and you can breathe i think the 80 is
really going to allow people to
feel comfortable that maybe haven't gone
out or don't go out as much
the number of patrons per table has also
increased from
6 to 12 as we are seeing here today but
it's important to mention even though
counties now have authority with making
decisions
in regards to what's best for their
communities the statewide
mask mandate remains in place the tavern
plans on having a holiday party
later today and this holiday party is to
honor all the holidays they missed
during the pandemic last year so if you
come on out and you see someone dressed
like the fourth of july or santa
you will know why so it's open to the
public reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now